- I haven't really opened
up about this very often.
- Giving us advice or
trying to joke about things
doesn't always work because
it's such a sensitive issue.
- It may have started out as a choice,
but at that point it was something
that I wanted to stop and couldn't stop.
- Eating disorders are
also a lot more mental
than you think they are.
- It's less about discipline than it is
kind of a compulsion.
- People with eating
disorders look very different.
- What I would want people to know is that
you don't have to put
yourself in my shoes.
- It's really not about
vanity or rational decisions.
It's just something
you know is destructive
but you can't really stop.
- I wish I could say that
there was this clear thing
where like I did this,
and then I got better.
- I compare it to addiction in that way.
- The only thing you have to worry about
is asking us how you can help.
- I think body image with guys needs to be
a much more open conversation.
- And sometimes that just means listening.
Sometimes that just means all you can do
is let us handle things because
that's what's working for us right now.